[Music]
stay tuned for a channel update at the
end of the video
[Music]
around the mid to late 90s many
franchises which were well established
by that point were about to make a big
transition into unknown territory
translating their characters gameplay
and general art style into the third
dimension
it's not like 3d technology was
completely non-existent by this point
in the early 90s wolfenstein 3d and doom
already demonstrated the possibilities
and even in the 80s there already
existed pseudo 3d games which used 3d
assets and camera positions to look 3d
though technically these are considered
to be 2.5 d
and even the aforementioned wolfenstein
doom and later duke nukem still relied
on flat sprites or billboards as they're
called in the industry
it's hard to pinpoint exactly which game
is the first true
3d game but quake released on june 22
1996
was the first game to use full 3d
objects for all props and characters
beating super mario 64 to the punch by
one day
though that game still uses 2d sprites
for stuff like collectibles and even
trees
even nintendo already made their leap
into the third dimension
years before with games like star fox on
the snes
but unlike games which saw their
inception as a 3d title
many franchises made their debut in two
dimensions
with the release of the nintendo 64
mario was nintendo's first candidate to
show off the potential
and well given the game's legacy it's
safe to say that they absolutely nailed
it
it single-handedly laid the groundwork
for all future platformers to come and
the team at nintendo made it look
almost effortless however during this
transition period it quickly became
apparent that it wasn't always smooth
sailing for
every franchise some games just seemed
like they were meant to be played in 2d
and in the case of metroid for example
it wasn't until the next gen that
nintendo finally felt comfortable to
make the transition
but we're not here to talk about those
games this is a video about
zelda and just like mario nintendo's
second most popular franchise made a
perfect transition into the third
dimension
blowing the competition out of the water
with ocarina of time
but as is with all bold new changes not
everyone prefers the new direction
to this day a link to the past is still
considered by many
to be their favorite zelda game of all
time and although ocarina adapted a lot
of the themes story beats and concepts
from its predecessor
it's undeniable that the experience is
radically different
luckily nintendo never forgot about the
old school approach and continues to
release zelda games in the classic style
alongside the 3d titles
the two different styles have co-existed
ever since but i think it's safe to say
that in terms of popularity the 2d
top down games have kind of been living
in the shadow of their bigger brothers
with the choice between more than 20
games and with the exception of the
classic games which still hold a lot of
nostalgic value for people
the majority of zela fans seem to prefer
the 3d installments over its top-down
counterparts
if they had to make a hard choice we
just don't see the same level of hype as
with the announcement of a 2d game
now i do realize that polls like these
don't represent the most accurate result
but i didn't want to draw conclusions on
the popularity of the two based on sales
numbers
because sales numbers are heavily
influenced by a lot of different factors
such as the popularity of the system it
released on how many systems it released
on
the time of release and the pricing as
an example link's crossbow training
actually sold more copies than skyward
sword but
i don't think anyone would claim that
crossbow training is the better game
now who am i kidding of course it's far
superior to skyward sword
joking aside though this obviously had
to do with the fact that the wii
was brand new at the time and that the
game was bundled together with the wii
zapper for a cheaper price
so in this case i think asking the
general public for their opinion
presents a more honest answer
and the margin of the polls don't lie
the 3d games
are by far more popular this is in stark
contrast to some of nintendo's other
franchises
as there are plenty of people who prefer
2d metroid over the prime series
or choose the classic side scroller
style of mario games over the 3d
platformers
anyway with everyone now focused on
breath of the wild too and the soon to
release hyrule warriors age of calamity
how does he even how does eva stay up
and he
is he's way too heavy oh i can't
excuse me like i said with everyone now
focused on these upcoming titles
i want to give some love to the other
side of the zelda fandom and discuss the
beauty of these games its game design as
well as the advantages and disadvantages
one has over the other
so without further delay let's dive into
the beauty of top down
zelda games first off i want to clarify
that although games like phantom
hourglass spirit tracks and a link
between worlds also use different
vantage points and camera angles i still
categorize these under the same umbrella
as the other top-down installments
since the majority of its gameplay is
still experienced from a bird's-eye
perspective
in order to prevent myself from going
all over the place
i've divided the subject matter into 6
different categories
accessibility difficulty combat story
dungeons
and exploration so let's start from the
top and work our way down starting with
for the average veteran gamer out there
getting into a 3d game
is no biggie especially for those who
grew up after the fifth generation of
consoles
but for the majority of the people on
the planet this is a whole different
story
just boot up breath the world and hand
over the controller to someone who has
little to no experience in gaming and
you will see how hard it is for them to
get a grip on it
3d games demand a lot more spatial
awareness not to mention the control
scheme is often a lot more complicated
the 2d titles are much more
straightforward and a lot easier to
comprehend for your average player
mind you this doesn't mean that the game
is easier to complete
something we'll get into next but only
two axes and a more clear overview of
where you are in the space around you is
definitely a lot less overwhelming and
thus
more accessible the simplicity of top
down zelda
is something i've always admired about
it there are of course games like a link
between worlds which require a lot more
spatial awareness due to his wall
merging mechanic
and for that reason alone i would never
recommend it to an unexperienced player
as their
first top down zelda game but it's still
a lot easier to get into than say
twilight princess or skyward sword
again easier to control not to finish
which leads into
the flip side of this easy to grasp
gameplay concept is that despite the
fact that the games look
a lot easier any veteran zelda player
out there knows that the opposite is
true
in most cases in fact up until breath of
the wild the 3d titles had been plagued
by a rather low
difficulty a little too low for my taste
actually
and even breath of the wild stops being
hard after
say 10 hours of gameplay the 2d games
have never been afraid to get really
difficult
and this can be both a blessing and a
curse for some the higher difficulty
might be a big turn off no matter your
preference though
i think there's a certain beauty to the
fact that these games aren't afraid to
pose a good challenge to any player
regardless of age or experience
with the exception of maybe the first
zelda on nes
the games generally don't start off too
hard if we take a link to the past for
example it isn't until the turning point
of the game after getting transported to
the dark world that the difficulty
suddenly ramps up significantly
enemies are suddenly way stronger and
deal a lot more damage
the dark world truly hits hard during a
first playthrough
but by that point you've already had
plenty of time to get some good practice
and with some perseverance you will be
able to deal with the challenges ahead
the only 3d title which comes close to
this is ocarina of time
and it's blatantly obvious just how much
inspiration this title took from a link
to the past
the child section of the game is pretty
easy but as soon as you become an adult
the game makes a radical change
dungeons are suddenly a lot bigger and
more complex enemies more dangerous
and even the overall atmosphere
communicates a certain message of
you're an adult now playtime is over
it's by no means as hard as a link to
the past dark world but definitely came
the closest
unless you count majora's mask which was
weird confusing and hard to get into
from the moment you booted up the game
but
yeah that's majira's mask for you but
even then most of the difficulty from
the 3d games comes from that spatial
awareness i was talking about earlier
and some of the puzzle elements that
come with it
but in terms of actual survival the top
down games are definitely in a league of
their own
my very first zelda game was ocarina of
time and even on my very first
playthrough i must have died only around
5 or 6 times
i didn't play a link to the past until
after majora's mask in the gap between
majora and waiting for the wind waker to
come out and
oh boy safe to say i died a lot
but after finishing it i was hooked and
immediately picked up link's awakening
right after
and finished both the oracle games as
well so that's 4
classic top down zelda games i tackled
in less than two years time
you can imagine that when the wind waker
came out the challenge of that game was
kind of underwhelming to say the least
coming off of ocarina of time majora's
mask and then
four very challenging 2d titles which
brings us to the next segment
the main culprit for the higher
difficulty found in the top down games
is death a lot of deaths
these games can be absolutely
unforgivable they are by no means among
the hardest games out there like
castlevania or ninja gaiden with the
exception of zelda 2 which we don't talk
about here but they
are miles ahead of the 3d games i think
this has to do with the whole z target
lock-on system
the enemies in the 3d titles are
generally designed and programmed to be
tackled one by one
i mean look at this what's this other
guy doing why isn't he attacking me
in the top-down games enemies don't care
they will gang up on you
and eat your hylian ass for breakfast if
you're not careful
for me personally this is one of the
most fun aspects of these types of zelda
games
you enter a room full of enemies and you
gotta make quick decisions
how do i navigate the room safely what
are my escape options which enemies
should i attack first
do i get rid of the weaker enemies to
clear some room to move
or do i go straight for the stronger
ones or the ones who litter the room
with projectiles
funnily enough this type of combat
challenge has also been proven to work
in the 3d games as well with places like
the savage labyrinth the cave of shadows
and more recently the trial of the sword
in breath of the wild
where you actually have to study the
room and plan your tactics ahead of time
instead of just mindlessly picking off
enemies one by one like in regular
dungeons
but for some reason this is mostly saved
as an extra optional challenge in the 3d
installments
another thing that contributes to the
combat being harder in the top down
games is that your window of
invulnerability
is a lot less lenient as is the hit stun
on enemies
if you're not careful or impatient you
can get combo to death
real quickly and some enemies cannot
just mindlessly be whaled on as they
have little or
even no hits done at all compare a dark
nut from the first game to the ones from
twilight princess or the wind waker and
it becomes clear just how brutal they
used to be
it's always moving and predicting where
they will go next and what your optimal
approach is without the risk of getting
in its path
is hard in the 3d games it's just a
matter of blocking and parrying at the
right moments which
honestly is more about patience than it
is about skill
i think you get the point so let's go
into something completely different
zelda games have historically been more
about gameplay first story second
and the 2d games definitely live and
breathe that mentality
the story in these installments can be
very interesting but at the same time it
also keeps it very simple
and because of its art style and
text-based conversations they are
definitely not on par with the other
games in terms of cinematics
the 3d games simply feel bigger and more
epic even if the total amount of
gameplay hours of a top down game is
the same or even longer seeing a cute
little sprite perform all these funny
little movements while you read the
dialogue box underneath
definitely has its charm but i can
totally see why people aren't as
invested in the story of these games
than they are with the others
however if there's one thing the
top-down games have over the rest
is that they are much more experimental
and dare to take a lot more risks
think about it the only 3d title that
doesn't take place in hyrule
is majora's mask i mean okay in skyward
sword hyrule technically hasn't been
founded yet but it's still in the same
geographical location
compare that to the 2d games which have
holodrum labrena
coal and island new hyrule and yes i
will even count hightopia
all brand new kingdoms to explore the
same thing goes for villains
only two of the 3d titles don't feature
ganondorf as the main bad guy
sure we have supporting villains like
girohim and zen but compared to the 2d
titles
this is still child's play vati bellum
malidus
varan general onox the nightmare from
link's awakening
the lady and a fair share of new
supporting villains like yuga and
chancellor cole
it seems like in terms of variety and
story narrative and characters the 2d
games are the place to be
and i don't exactly know why perhaps
because nintendo views the 3d titles as
the more important
mainline games now they are more afraid
to step away from the norm and take
risks than they do with the other games
it's hard to say for sure this also goes
for certain gameplay elements
there's a lot of talk about breath of
the wild 2 possibly featuring co-op mode
between link and zelda which would be a
first for the 3d titles
meanwhile the 2d games have been
experimenting with multiplayer since the
first four swords and if breath the
while 2 doesn't feature co-op but rather
sees you switching between link and
zelda that too
has already been done to a certain
degree in spirit tracks
granted this last aspect doesn't really
have a whole lot to do with the story
specifically
but i didn't know where else to include
it so i thought i'd just mention it here
dungeons are a very subjective matter
when it comes to zelda
i am personally torn in terms of which
style i like the most
though i will say that the imposing size
and complexity of the 3d dungeons does
speak to me just a little bit more but
not by a large margin
there are plenty of 2d dungeons which i
vastly prefer
over some of the 3d ones however the
biggest strength of the 3d dungeons is
the variety in their aesthetics and
atmosphere
with the more recent top-down titles
this definitely has improved and
dungeons no longer feel like simple
palette swaps but i'd still give the
edge to the 3d
installments in that department there's
just something about experiencing a
dungeon from all angles that makes it
stand out more
but again like with the story the 2d
games have been a lot more experimental
in terms of actual dungeon mechanics
if i look back at just how crazy these
dungeons can get sometimes
i can't help but feel inspired as
someone who loves talking about game
design
so many different mechanics which
completely change the way you approach
these challenges
making an entire floor crash into the
floor below to access new areas
throwing ice down a shaft to freeze the
floor below using certain switches to
loop around the dungeon
having to travel between two different
dimensions to progress further
some dungeons are about finding loads
and loads of keys and
not all keys are required to beat the
dungeon whereas others barely feature
any keys at all i don't know why but it
just feels a lot easier to get lost than
having to think outside the box in these
dungeons than it is in the 3d
installments
in those games it can feel a lot more
formulaic at times
emphasis on most of the time there are
definitely exceptions
additionally sometimes dungeons in the
2d games also feature multiple exits and
entrances
which in the example of skull woods the
dungeon is entirely designed around
something that's a lot more scarce in
the other games and is never utilized to
this extent
in general there's also a lot more
optional rooms in these dungeons as well
and you know i get it designing an
entirely optional 3d space which the
player might never visit can feel like a
waste of precious development time
but that doesn't take away from the fact
that this does make the dungeons in the
top-down games feel a lot more of a
challenge
overall again i want to emphasize that
these are generalizations
there are very simple and
straightforward 2d dungeons and very
complex 3d ones
last but not least i want to touch upon
exploration
now i could never say with a straight
face that the exploration in any of the
2d games is better than the one
found in breath the wild at the same
time the reason why breath the wild's
exploration is so amazing is exactly
because it wanted to capture the feeling
of the first game on the nes
so there's that but aside from breath of
the wild a lot of the overworld
exploration in the 3d games before
was heavily toned down skyward sword
alright to be fair though this isn't
entirely the fault of the games
themselves
3d games demand a lot more power in
terms of hardware and up until breath of
the wild the technology just
wasn't there the worlds needed to be
bottlenecked and divided up into chunks
to make it work
but if there's anything the top-down
games have over its 3d brothers it's
that the secrets feel a lot
more secret like especially in the
earlier games because each screen was
more self-contained it was much easier
to hide stuff in very random spots
without making it impossible for the
player to find
caves chests and sometimes even a
dungeon could be hidden under a
seemingly random bush
rock or inside of a wall and because
you're viewing the world from a bird's
eye perspective
the game designers have an easier time
placing subtle hints in the terrain
assets
something that's a lot harder when
you're viewing the world from behind the
protagonist or from first person
try hiding a big secret in a random bush
or patch of grass in breath of the wild
yeah that'll go over well in general
it's a lot harder to miss stuff in the
top down games
since all the information is laid out in
front of you whereas in breath of the
wild you could walk by a hillside
not realizing there's something
significant right behind it
which is why in the case of breath of
the wild the zelda team expertly
implemented high vantage points and
paragliding to spot these secrets from
afar
in the 3d installments before breath of
the wild nintendo needed to be
a lot more obvious with their secrets
there are some very well hidden ones in
ocarina of time but because hyrule field
is so small and barren you're still a
lot less likely to miss them
additionally if you had a rumble pack
you had the option to use the stone of
agony to track these secrets down
and because some of these secrets would
have been close to impossible to find
without the rumble feature
none of the rewards are really all that
special and only of real interest to the
hardcore completionists out there
all in all i think it's a wonderful
thing that the 2d games still have their
place in the zelda franchise
they are not comparable to the mainline
3d titles
and that is exactly why these games
should always make their stay
sure they might not generate the same
kind of hype we find with the other
games
but whether you like it or not this is
how zelda started and how it pulled
millions of people into the fandom
as of late i've become a bit worried
about the 2d installments
even after the series made its
transition into 3d there was a time
especially in the 2000s that we got a
constant influx of amazing top-down
zelda games
we had oracle of ages and seasons in
2001
minish cap four swords and four swords
adventures in 2004
phantom hourglass in 2007 with spirit
tracks following less than two years
later in 2009
then things started slowing down a bit
more with a link between worlds in 2013
and the last brand new top down zelda
game we've gotten since then was
triforce heroes in 2015 and yeah we had
link's awakening in 2019 but that's not
a brand new zelda game but rather a
remake of a game from 1993
i'm not necessarily against remix but i
think i'm not alone in saying that i
would have vastly preferred a new zelda
game in this style than a remake of a
game i
already played decades ago not only that
but by remaking link's awakening
nintendo is setting themselves up for
having to remake the oracle games and
maybe even minish cap now too
development time which i would rather
see go towards a new experience
and yes i know these games are being
developed by a third party but that's
not really an excuse capcom which is
also a third party developed three
amazing top-down zelda games under the
direction of nintendo 4 if you also
count the first four swords game which
came bundled with diminish cap
now that the 3ds has been discontinued
and the switch basically merged
nintendo's handheld and console market
i sincerely hope that the classic zelda
style of games aren't thrown by the
wayside and demoted to mostly remakes
a good brand new top-down adventure is
always a great experience
and an excellent way to fill the void
between the 3d installments which
usually only release every four to five
years or so
and now for a channel update because man
my voice is really
starting to go as some of you with a
sharp eye may have noticed there's now
an additional button underneath my
videos
and on my channel page litwooden
oh wait uh join that's right the gods of
the google sphere have deemed me
worthy for channel memberships so if
patreon isn't really your bag but you
still want to support the channel
financially without having to go to a
third party website then this option is
now available
the memberships include similar perks
like getting your name into credits
alongside my patreons early access to
certain videos
if the deadline is lenient enough and in
the future i will do some behind the
scenes stuff as well like showing you
how i make some of my videos like the
hero's path for instance
and maybe even little tutorials since as
an example i get a lot of questions
about how the 3d map of wrath the wild
works in my animations
but of course what really matters is you
will gain access to 4 different emojis
to use in the comment section of my
videos and community posts
these include cat dog
bald mummy ganondorf and of course we
cannot go without the zone iced whirl
as of right now i'm restricted to only
four but these will be expanded later
down the line as i gain more members
again i want to make it perfectly clear
you being here and watching my videos is
already
amazing to me and i am not going to
treat people differently in the comments
and only respond or give hearts to
members this is purely for those who
deem my channel worthy enough
i guess for some additional support and
have the means to do so
i also want to quickly mention that a
discord is now in the works
i still have a little bit of work left
to do but this shouldn't take too long
as it stands right now i'm planning to
open up the gates somewhere in the next
two weeks
also also since some people have been
asking the last heroes path episode is
still in the works
if it were up to me i would have
released it earlier but i also need to
have consideration for the schedule of
my co-host who has been rather busy as
of late
as not to paint myself in a corner with
promises i will just say for now it will
come out before the release of age of
calamity
sooner rather than later however not
next week as
that one will be reserved for a spooky
scary halloween episode
this is my favorite holiday so i
definitely don't want to miss out on the
first halloween celebration on this
channel
a big thanks for watching this video and
as always a big thanks to my amazing
patreons
since the heroes path videos didn't have
any vocal shout outs at the end i have a
bit of catching up to do so
please welcome chris woodall harm dykman
sexalla
rocket cat barky doggo shigeko
eric turtles brick hobie patrick
montyoth
as well as an additional mention to
didachu for upgrading their pledge
if i happen to have missed anyone feel
free to message me on patreon
and i will make it up to you in the next
one thank you all so much for your
support
i will see you in the next video this is
dawn signing off
and have a good one
you